avec plus de 160 mille cas recensés et
un bilan qui a franchi les 3000 morts
sur son sol les etats unis sont
aujourd'hui le pays le plus touché au
monde par la pandémie à new york pour
tenter de soulager les établissements de
santé submergé un hôpital de campagne a
vu le jour dans le très célèbre central
park un endroit choisi pour sa proximité
avec l'hôpital du quartier disent harlem
en général lorsque nous intervenons nous
mettons en place ce qu'on appelle un
hôpital de campagne d'urgence
spécifiques à la catastrophe
en irak nous avions installé deux salles
d'opération mais ici nous disposons
d'une unité de soins respiratoires
nous nous concentrons donc sur
l'assistance respiratoire sur l'apport
en oxygène
c'est surréaliste d'être ici à new york
personne aux états unis ne s'attendait à
une épidémie de cette ampleur mais nous
considérons de la même manière que les
gens ont besoin des deux tout comme ils
en auraient besoin à l'étranger et
toujours pour soulager les centres
médicaux de la ville
un navire hôpital militaire est arrivé
lundi matin dans le port de new york
sa mission accueillir les patients non
atteints par le cos vide 19 mai ayant
besoin de soins d'urgence le maire de
new york en personne salue l'arrivée de
l'ue sns comfort doté d'une capacité de
1000 lits avec l'arrivée de ce navire
il ne s'agit pas seulement de l'aide qui
arrive sous forme physique
elle ne s'agit pas que de lits
supplémentaires de médecins et de
matériel il s'agit aussi d'espoir s'agit
aussi de remonter le moral des new
yorkais qui traverse un moment difficile
il s'agit de dire à nos héros dans les
hôpitaux que l'aide est arrivée
notre nation a entendu l'appel à l'aide
de new york il ne pourrait y avoir de
meilleur symbole de toute l'amérique qui
rassemble ses forces pour new york que
l'arrivée du sns comme forte
c'est un grand grand moment dans cette
longue lutte contre le coronavirus
et ailleurs dans le pays les centres de
dépistage se multiplient c'est notamment
le cas dans le maryland où le parking
d'un stade de football américain a été
réquisitionné les états unis qui
pourraient connaître lors du week-end de
pâques un pic de l'épidémie
donald trump avait initialement prévu
d'alléger les mesures de confinement à
cette date il s'est depuis ravisé
sur les conseils du corps médical